[Music]
if you joined the crowd at Notting Hill
Carnival this bank holiday weekend you
could be scanned identified and tracked
in real time thanks to facial
recognition Sky News has learned that
more than 20 million facial images are
now held by the police which could
correspond to nearly a third of the UK
population it's the second year police
have trialed the technology and carnival
and it's being deployed more and more
Leicestershire Police have previously
used it at a festival and football fans
attending the Champions League final
here in Cardiff in June were also
scanned but in his first ever
interviewed the independent biometrics
commissioner has told Sky News that
pressing ahead with the technology poses
risks if the police start deploying a
technology without as understanding what
it will do and without any government
government framework legislative
framework or independent oversight then
I think that will undermine trust in the
police then you're perfectly right there
is this question about invasion of
individual privacy and the needs to be a
proper balance between whatever the
public interest is claimed and the
interference in that individual privacy
surveillance is obviously crucial to the
police and intelligence they just come
to terrorism makes it even more vital or
facial recognition allows though is the
computer to pick your face out of a
crowd rather than just being kept tabs
on your tracks in real-time it's mass
surveillance for the physical world
facial recognition has advanced
dramatically over the last five years
thanks to machine learning and
artificial intelligence this British
company says its recognition systems get
ten times more accurate every three to
six months and that they're being used
by counterterrorism agencies around the
world every day what you're seeing now
is a real-life demo state of the art is
changing and what we have now is the
ability to do much more in the real
world in real time that's what we're
showing today is a capability that can
be much more in the Jason Bourne style
ie we're looking for people in the real
world as they go about their everyday
lives the Met told us the deployment of
the cameras is to test the technology
and was implemented following closely
azon with the Information Commissioner
and Big Brother watch
once the trial is complete we will be
analyzing the results and holding a
public consultation the overall picture
for policing is patchy through Freedom
of Information requests Sky News has
found that three police forces used the
technology for the Champions League
final though South Wales police only
conducted a privacy assessment after
plans have been put in place to monitor
tens of thousands of fans under
facial-recognition the Home Office was
supposed to publish a biometric strategy
keeping regulations on how to use facial
recognition three years ago
it still hasn't this should not be
happening in a policy vacuum that's I
think the key point then the government
needs to set out what its position is on
this how we balance security against
privacy how we reassure the public that
this technology is going to be used
properly it's not just police and
intelligence agencies who use facial
recognition businesses are getting into
it too adverts can be targeted you in
real time by detecting your gender your
age and even your emotions this is an
unsettling future one that so far the
public has had little say over Tom
Cheshire Sky News